Hey guys, Pete here. This will be my Dark
season 3 family trees video. The
final season of this Netflix original
series answered most of the questions
related to the four families at the
center of the knot that is Winden, but
due to the looping nature of some of the
family relations it's a lot to take in
and keep track of. In this Dark season 3
video I'll be talking about the family
connection revelations we got, and that
will contain spoilers that would
potentially ruin things if you haven't
finished the series. For that reason I
wouldn't recommend watching this video
until you've completed the entire third
season. I do have a family tree video
that I'll link to up at the top if you
want to get a refresher of who's who
while you're watching season 3. Alright
then. We did get some major revelations
in how things are connected with the
families in Dark and it turns out that
Jonas and Martha are the center of it all.
Of course, when I say Martha I'm talking
about the one from the alternate world.
the Martha from seasons 1 & 2 who Jonas
fell in love with only to find out she
was his aunt is dead and makes no
further contributions to the family
trees. For that reason I'm not gonna say
"alt" every time I say her name.
This Martha, the one from the alternate
world, is at the center of everything
because she conceived a child with Jonas. Since we've all watched the season
I won't retell the story in this video,
but in relation to the families Martha
saves Jonas from the apocalypse in his
world and brings him to hers. He then
meets a slightly younger version of her
who doesn't know anything about time
travel yet and they end up sleeping
together. She gets pregnant as a result
and that turns out to be the beginning
of all the family tree insanity. She
gives birth to a character that we've
been calling "the Trio" due to the fact
that he appears as three characters.
Three versions of the same character at
different points in his life - a boy, an
adult,
and an old man. This character explains
he was never given a name and is
referred to as "The Unknown" in the
credits and official show materials. The
Unknown answers one of the biggest
questions we've had. Agnes Nielsen was
the farthest point back on the Nielsen
family line and we had no idea who
fathered her son.
According to the official website the
Unknown conceived Tronte in both worlds
with Agnes. Tronte then is the father of
Ulrich, who is the father of Martha, but
also the grandfather of Jonas. it's an
infinite cycle. a massive knot with the
Unknown at the center. on screen we don't
see the Unknown and Agnes together, and
we never visit the time when she was
pregnant with Tronte. The explanation
just says that he was conceived in both
worlds by the same parents. another big
question we had about Agnes and her
brother Noah was who their parents were.
season 3 gives us that answer and it
turns out to be Silja and Bartosz
Tiedemann. Bartosz of course was Jonas's
highschool friend that was saved by
stranger Jonas at the end of season 2. he
ended up in 1888 and was eventually
killed by younger Noah, who turned out to
be his son, in 1921. Silja was taken care
of by Elisabeth Doppler in the future
until she was sent back to 1890 and meets
Bartosz. they become a couple and have Noah
and Agnes together with Silja dying
while giving birth to their daughter.
this is a good time to discuss the
differences in how the family tree plays
out in Adam's and Eva's worlds. in the
official family tree we can see that
many of the relationships still exist
but we don't get to see how they played
out in Eva's world. Silja and Bartosz are
still Agnes parents but we never
actually meet Silja in her world. Bartosz follows a much different path
through time, but as far as the family
trees are concerned we end up in the
same place. Silja's parentage is another
example of this. we learned that her
parents are Hannah and Egon in Adam's
world. she traveled back to 1954 and met
him there. they have an affair in that
time period and she gives birth to Silja
after leaving him. eventually she travels
back in time where Jonas / Adam kills
her and he sends Silja to the future
where she grows up until we first meet
her in 2052. In Ava's world it isn't
clear when this happens since Hannah is
married to Ulrich in the 2019 timeline
and Egon is a travelling member of
Eva's group Erit Lux.
the only time we see them together is
when Egon rescues her from the
apocalypse in that world. at that time
Hannah was pregnant with Ulrich's child
but she suffers a miscarriage right as
Egon is arriving. Egon and his first
wife Doris are the parents of Claudia
Tiedemann. Claudia is the mother of
Regina who gets cancer in both worlds,
but we never knew for sure who her
father was.
Tronte was the most likely candidate
because we knew that they had a
relationship, but it turns out that Bernd
Doppler was Regina's father all along.
this felt someone out of the blue since
there were no hints to an intimate
relationship, but it turns out to be
important since it means that Regina is
not a direct descendant of the Jonas and
Martha's line. Regina's husband Aleksander
has a mysterious backstory that fans
have long theorized about. he was born
Boris Niewald
and arrived in Winden with a gunshot
wound carrying the pistol that will
travel through time and later be used by
Adam to kill Martha from his world. he
used that to run off teen Katharina and
Ulrich who were threatening Regina and
the two form a relationship that sees
them get married and give birth to
Bartosz. his entrance into the story led
to many theories about him being a time
traveler or at least manipulated by one,
but in the end it turns out he was a guy
on the run. in Eva's world he tells his
son that he killed a man in Marburg, but
it was an accident. he played a role in
the apocalypse in both worlds as
director of the power plant, but he was
just a criminal who went straight after
fleeing to Winden and meeting his wife.
speaking of the power plant, Bernd
Doppler's wife Greta expressed doubt
about him being Helge's real father. in
a conversation with Noah she says the
boy was not born out of love
leading to speculation that she may
have been raped. we don't get a full
explanation of the story here but the
family tree does give us a name and
confirms that Bernd is not Helga's
father. the name is Anatol Veliev but
there's no information about this
character. Helge's son Peter has also
been the source of many theories because
we only had a vague backstory of him
arriving in Winden in 1987. season 3
explained that Helge is his father but
he didn't know about him until
shortly before his mother died. his
mother's name was Ulla Schmidt but we
don't have any other details about her
life or relationship with Helge. in the
end like Boris Niewald Peter's story
turned out to be just what it looked
like on the surface. of course he does
get together with Charlotte in both
worlds and pitches in on the bootstrap
paradox relationship between his wife
and daughter. that they are each other's
mothers was one of the big reveals in
season 2 and I find it funny looking at
the new family tree since it's not even
really emphasized. now that we know the
origin theirs is just one loop out of many.
Charlotte's adopted grandfather HG Tannhaus is a character we learned a lot
about in the final season. we learned
that his great-grandfather Heinrich was
the founder of Sic Mundus and the origin
of the gold pocket watch.
Heinrich initially gave the watch as a
gift to his wife Charlotte who later
died. he started Sic Mundus to learn how
to time travel in order to try to bring
her back from the dead. he passes the
watch on to his son Gustav who we meet.
he's the blind man who owns the factory
where stranger Jonas is working on the
time machine. he was killed by the
Unknown as he was on his way to tell the
world about the Time Traveler's he met -
stranger Jonas and Martha. the Unknown
takes the watch from him and it starts
its journey through time.
Gustav Tannhaus' grandson HG is the
clock maker we met in the first two
seasons, and he turns out to be the
catalyst for everything in a third
"origin" world. I discussed all of this in
my ending explained video and will
probably revisit it in future videos, but
in relation to the family trees the
website does have an easter egg. if you
scroll all the way through Jonas or
Martha's pages the origin worlds family
tree will appear. by default you just see
mirrored versions of the family tree for
Adam and Eva's worlds. we learned in the
closing scene of the series that some of
the characters from the origin world are
the same, but none of the characters that
are direct descendants of Jonas and
Martha through the Unknown exist. this
origin world family tree shows Claudia
and Bernd are married in this world
making Regina's last name Doppler. we get
confirmation that Hannah and Torben are married making
her last name Woller. we can see that in
a world without Charlotte Peter winds up
with Bernadette Woller and that even
though Boris Niewald exists it doesn't
look like he ever gets together with
Regina. there's other characters that we
never saw on-screen, these characters
parents that are in the family tree but
there isn't any additional information
about their lives in the origin world. we
do see Katharina here her last name is
still Albers and that was one other
reveal that we got in the third season
that her parents were Hermann and Helene
Albers. of course we saw her mother kill
her, she was the nurse at the psychiatric
unit where Ulrich was living out his
years. Hermann Albers was the man that
Egon talked to when the sheep died back
in season one, and that pretty much wraps
things up. as mentioned the biggest
reveal is that all of this starts and
essentially ends with Jonas and Marta. on
a bigger scale it starts with HG Tannhaus
who like his great grandfather is
obsessed with time travel because he
wants to go back and save someone who
died. we see this theme repeated
throughout the different worlds and in a
way it seems quite fitting that Jonas
and Martha who would never have existed
in the origin world are able to complete
this process making for at least a
reality where Tannhaus' family never
dies and he never decides to invent a
time machine. what an absolute mess and
knot. it does feel great to have all the
answers now. there's a couple things
there. some people we don't know. they
never told us who Hannah's mother was or
or Daniel Kahnwald's wife but in the end
they didn't turn out to be important but
beyond that we did get answers to all
the big questions and with that I think
I'll leave it there. let me know in the
comments what you think. did you catch
all this? were you able to keep track of
it while you were watching season 3 ?do
you have any other questions about the
family trees that I didn't cover? I'll be
making more Dark videos this week so let
me know if you have any ideas in the
comments as well as mentioned I did put
out an ending explain video you should
check that out if you haven't please
like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'll put
a link in the description to the
official website where all these family
trees come from a lot of your questions
can be answered there they filled in a
lot of blanks I've been going through
that for days at this point and that's
about it thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon